the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free to make a donation or to view
additional materials from hundreds of
MIT courses visit MIT opencourseware at
ocw.mit.edu
alright well I want to thank you all for
coming to what I've advertised as
penultimate course in this lecture
series everything else we've got done up
to this point has sort of been building
up to actually finally really using
databases you know and hopefully you
haven't been too disappointed at how
long I've sort of led you let you let
you along here to get to this point but
but the point being that if you have
certain abstract concepts in your mind
that once we get to the database part it
just feels very straightforward if we do
the database piece and you don't have
those concepts then you can easily get
distracted by sort of extraneous
information so today there's no snow
view graphs so I'm sure you're all
thrilled about that it's going to be all
demos showing interacting with the
actual technologies that we have here
everything I'm showing t is stuff that
you can use I mean so everyone has been
so I'm just going to kind of get into
this and let's just start with step one
we're going to be using the cumulative
basis that we've set up we have sort of
a clearinghouse of these databases on RL
grid system and you can get to that list
by going to this website web page here
DB status LOL mit.edu and when you go
there it will prompt to you for your one
password and then it will show you the
databases that you have access to now I
have access to all the databases but you
guys should only have see these class
databases when you if you if you log
into that and um and so as you see here
we have five databases that are set up
these are five independent instances of
accumulated a couple already and we can
even take a look at them so this is what
a running accumulo instance looks like
this is its main page here it shows you
kind of how much disk is you
using the number of tables and all that
type of stuff then it gives you a nice
history that shows ingest rate you know
over the last few bid and scan rate this
is all in entries per second ingesting
megabytes all different kinds of really
useful information here and you'll see
that this is got the URL of class DB 01
cloud ll grid and that's been a you know
when I started it it was an actual
machine that was allocated to that fact
just for fun here I could turn one of
these on um you guys are free to start
them I would encourage you to hit the
stop button because if someone else is
using it and you get stopped then you
know that could be that could be that
may not be something you want to do but
it's the same setup for instance if you
have a project everyone in the class can
see this because we've made you all part
of the the class group but you can see
here there's other classes we have a
bioinformatics group and they have a
couple of databases those are theirs
you're not running right now there's a
very large graph database group it's
running now and just to show this is
it's running you see this has about 200
gigabytes data in and if we look in the
tables here we see here we have a few
tables here here are some tables with a
few billion entries that have been put
in there and this is really what
accumulate is very very well but i'm
going to start one just for fun here
that works so it will be starting that
all that happens and so you can and you
can see it's starting and all those type
of stuff so we're going to get going
here now with these specific examples
all right and i have these just so you
know today's example so it's in the
examples directory in the scaling
directory and two parallel database so
this is the directory we're going to be
going through today and I mean we have a
lot of examples to get through because
we're going to be covering a lot of
ground here about how you can take
advantage of D for em
and a key melot together here so the
first thing I'm going to do is go here
I'm going to run these I have
essentially two versions of the code one
that's going to do fairly smaller
databases on my laptop and then have
another version that's sitting in my
yellow grid account that I can do some
bigger things with so so to get started
we're going to do this first example PvP
01 data test
alrighty so in order to do database work
and to test data we need to generate
some data and so i'm using a built-in
data generator that we have called the
chronic or graph it's basically borrowed
from a benchmark called the graph 500
benchmark there's actually a list called
graph 500 and I helped write that
benchmark and in fact I actually the
matlab code on that website is stuff
that i originally voted wrote and other
people have have since modified and so
this is a graph generator generates a
very large power law graph using a
Kronecker product approach and it has a
few parameters here a scale parameter
which is basically the number of
vertices so to to this scale parameter
is approximately the number of vertices
so 2 to the 12th gets you about what
4,000 vertices it then creates a certain
number of edges per vertex so 16 edges
per vertex and so this cute you know
computes n max is 2 to the scale here
and then the number of edges is I just
per vertex times and max does the
maximum number it is and then it and
then it generates this and it comes back
with two vectors which is just the list
of the the first list is a vector is a
list of starting vertices on the second
vector is a list of ending vertices and
we're not really using any d forum here
we're just creating a sparse adjacency
matrix of the data showing it and then
plotting the degree distribution so if
we look at that figure so this shows the
adjacency matrix of this graph start
vertex end vertex these chronic or
graphs have this sort of recursive
structure and if you kept zooming in you
would see that the graph looked like
itself ostrava in a recursive way here
that's what gives us this this power law
distribution there's a relatively small
graph on this particular data generator
is chosen because
you can make enormous graphs in parallel
very easily which is something that if
we had to pass around large data sets
every single time we wanted to test our
software it would be prohibitive because
we'd be passing around you know
gigabytes and terabytes and i think i
think the largest this has ever been run
on is on a scale of 2 to the 37 so
that's trillions of trillions of
vertices or certainly billions of
vertices almost trillions of vertices
and then we do the degree distribution
of this and you see here it creates a
power-law distribution we have a few
vertices with only one connection and we
always have a super node with a lot of
connections and you can see actually
hear the the chronic or structure in
this in this in this data which is it
creates this characteristics or sawtooth
a pattern and there's ways to get rid of
that if you want but for our purposes
having that structure there there's no
problem with that so this is kind of a
exactly what the Assad agree
distribution looks like so that's just a
small version to show you kind of what
the data looks like now we're going to
create a bigger version ok so this
program which will now show you so this
program creates essentially the same
chronic or graph and but it's going to
do it eight times and the right one of
the nice things about this generator is
those will be you can if you just keep
calling this it gives you more
independent samples from the same graph
so we're just sort of creating a graph
that's got eight times as many edges the
previous one just by calling it over and
over again just from the random number
generator so I have 8 i'm going to do
this eight times and i'm going to save
each one of those to a separate file so
i create a file name i'm actually
setting the random number seed to be set
by the the file name so that i can do
this if I wanted you know if I the
seventh file will always have
essentially the same a random sequence
regardless of when I run it and so I
create my vertices and I'm going to
convert these two strings and then write
the now write these out two files and so
that's all that does here and one of the
things I do throughout this process that
you will see is I keep track of how many
edges per second i'm generating thanks
so here i'm generating you know about
150,000 it varies in terms of the edges
per second here but you know between
30,000 and 150 or 180,000 edges per
second because when you're creating a
whole data processing pipeline that's
essentially the kind of the metrics
you're looking you know sums some steps
may generate you know process your edges
extremely quickly and other steps might
process your edges more slowly and
that's obviously the ones where you want
to put poor more energy and effort into
it so we can actually now go and look
it's stuck it in this data directory
here and we just created that and so we
basically we write it out on three files
essentially each one of these holds one
part of a triple so a column a row a
column and a value so if we look at the
row you can just see it's a sequence of
strings separated by commas same with a
column is to separate the sequence of
strings so pretty like Acamas and then
in this case the values we just made all
ones nothing nothing fancy there so now
we have eight files alright that's great
we generated those very quickly and now
we want to do a little processing on
them so if we go the first thing we're
new is read those files back in and
construct associative arrays because the
associative reconstruction time takes a
little time and we're going to want to
use it over and over again so we might
as well take those triples and and
construct them into associative arrays
and save them out as Malibu nary files
and now that will be something that we
can work with very quickly so we're
going to do that all right so there you
go read them
in and it shows you at the rate at which
is reads them in and then essentially
writes them out and gives us another
example of the edges per second and now
you see we have matlab files for each
one of those and not surprising that the
matlab file is smaller than the three
input triples that it gave so this is a
24 kilobyte matlab file and you know is
probably about 80 kilobytes of input
data and that's just because you know
we've compressed all the row keys into
single vectors and we have the sparse
adjacency matrix which stores things and
so that makes it a little bit a little
bit better there we actually look at
that program here so we can see we
basically are reading it in and then
what we're doing is we're basically
creating an associative array we can
read in each set of triples okay and
then the constructor he takes the list
of roast rings column strings we just
all want this since we knew they were
all one we're just letting that be one
and then there's a optional fourth
argument that tells us what do we want
to do if we put in two triples you know
with the same row and column you know
what to do the default is it will just
do the min so if I have a collision it
will just do a min if I give it this
optional fourth argument at some in fact
you can put in essentially any binary
operation there but at some will just
add to add them together so now we'll
have at that in the associative array a
particular row and column will have how
many how many that occurred and so you
know we're we're summing up as we go
here and then after we create the
associative array we save them out to a
file and so we have that step done all
right now the whole reason I showed you
this process is because now i'm actually
a position i can start doing computation
just on the files as i said before you
don't have to use the database i can if
i'm going to do any kind of calculation
that's going to involve traversing all
the data it's going to be faster just to
read in those matlab files and do my
processing on that
it's also very easy to make parallel I
have a lot of files you know I just have
different if I launched a parallel job I
can just have different different
processes reading separate files it will
scale very well the the data ray read
rates will be very fast all you know
reading these files in parallel will
take much less time than trying to pull
out all the data from the database again
so we're going to do a little analytic
here or I'm going to basically compute
I'm going to take those eight files read
them all in and accumulate the results
as we go right and there we go thats we
get the the in degree distribution in
the app degree distribution of this of
this result look at that program here
you can see all we did is we looped over
all the files just loaded them from in
matlab and then basically summed the
rows and added that to attempt variable
and some the columns and then plotted
them out so we just sort of accumulated
them as we went this actually this
method of just summing on top and an
associative array is something that you
can certainly do it's very convenient
way to do it I should say though and you
can kind of see it here a little bit you
notice that the time is beginning to
well it's not so clear here this took so
little time but we'll on another larger
example you what you would see is that
every single time we did that because
we're building and then adding we're
basically redoing the construction
process and so eventually this will
become longer and longer and longer and
so it's okay for small stuff to do that
or if you're only going to do it a few
times if you're going to be accumulating
an enormous amount of data then what we
can actually do is we have another
version of this program dbo for
cast a great test and you can tell that
was a little bit faster you see here
it's all the milliseconds of time and so
in the way we did that and this is a
little bit longer program what we're
doing here is basically we're reading in
doing the exact same thing we're loading
our matlab file we're reading we're
doing the sum ok and then since I know
something about the structure of that
that is basically I'm summing the rose
okay i can just append that to a longer
list okay and then at the end do one
large sum and that's and then that's
that's obviously much much faster and so
these kind of tricks you just need to be
aware if you're trying to do very
whipping where you know people typically
want to do large amount of data you just
do the simple some that'll be okay but
if you're doing in a lot over a large
list that essentially becomes as almost
an N squared operation with the number
of the loop loop variable and this is
one that will be be even faster you can
make it even faster because we are doing
this concatenation here when you do a
concatenation in MATLAB you're doing a
Mallick if you want to make it even
faster you can pre-allocate a large
buffer and then append into that buffer
and then when you hit the edge you know
doux-doux a sum then and and do it and
do it that way and that's that would
even that's even fat that's the fastest
you can do so these are trick doing very
very large sums you can do them very
quickly and all with files you don't
need a database and this is the way to
go if you're going to be doing something
were an analytic where you really want
to traverse most of the data in the
database or in your data set if you just
need to get pieces of the data in the
database then the database will be be a
better tool all right
so all right we did did that so those
show how we did work with files all
right and that's always a good place to
start even if you are working with the
database if you find that you're doing
one query over and over again that
you're going to be then working with
that data a lot of times better do that
query and then save those results to a
file and then just work with that file
while you're doing anything and this is
something that people often do in our
business all right now we're going to
get to the actual database part of it
okay so first thing we're going to do is
we have to set up our database we're
going to create some tables in accumulo
and so we want to create those first so
they're created properly and so i'm
going to show you the program that does
that the first thing they're going to do
it's going to call a DB set up command
and so let me this this program going to
now show you that and so when you run
these examples you will have to modify
this DB setup program okay so the first
thing you'll you'll notice is that we're
all using the same for each group this
is with those databases is all using one
user account and you can say well that's
not the best way to do it well it's very
consistent with the group structure in
that is basically all users your the
databases there to share data amongst
your group and so it is not an uncommon
practice to have a single user account
in which you put that data so we have a
bit of a namespace problem if you all
just ran this example together you'd all
create the exact same table and all you
know fill it up so the first thing we're
going to do is just prepend the tables
and I would suggest you put your name
you replace instead of having my name
there you put your name there and then
we have a special command here called DB
set up LOL grid which basically creates
a binding to a database just using the
name of the database so it's a special
function that's not a generic function
only works with our elegant system and
it only works if you have mounted the
elegant file system so
hide all this stuff here so as you see
here I have mounted the yellow grid file
system okay and and and you need to do
that because the DB set up command when
it binds to the database it actually
goes get the keys from the yellow grid
filesystem and those keys are sitting in
the group directory for that so
basically from a password management
perspective all we need to do is add you
to the group and then you have access to
the database or if we remove you from
the group you no longer have access to
the database so that's how we do
otherwise we'd have to distribute a a
keys to every single user all the time
and so this is this is why we do that so
this greatly simplifies it but you will
not be able to make a connection to the
yellow to one of these databases unless
you are either logged in to your lr it
account or if you're on your computer
you've mounted the the file system + d 4
m knows where to look for the keys when
you when you pass in that set of command
all right here so so if we look at that
again so and this is just a shorthand
for the full DB server command so if you
were connecting some to some database
directly other than one of these or you
could even do with these you would have
to pass in essentially a five argument
thing which is the the the the host name
of the computer and the port the name of
the instance the name of the I guess
there's a couple instance names here and
then the name of the user and then an
actual password and so that's the
generic way to connect in general but
for the those of you connected to Ella
grid we can we can just use this
shorthand which is very nice then we're
going to build
a couple of tables so we have these
first thing we're going to do is we're
going to want to create a table that's
going to hold that adjacency matrix that
I just created in with the files and so
we're going to do that with a database
pair so if we have our database object
here we give it to string names it will
know to create two tables in in the
database and return a binding to that
table that's a pair it's a transposed
pair so whenever we do an insert into
that table it will insert you know the
row in the column and in one table and
then flip those and insert the column in
the row and the other table and then
whenever you do a lookup it will know if
it's doing a row look up to look on one
table and if it's doing a column look up
to do on the other table and this will
allows you to do fast lookups of both
rows and columns and make it all nice
for you we're also going to want to take
advantage of a cumulus built-in ability
to some as we insert and so we're going
to create something that's going to hold
the degree as we go very useful to have
these statistics because a lot of times
you want to look up something and then
you but the first thing you want to do
is just see well how many of them are in
there and so if you create a essentially
a column vector with that information
very helpful I'll later we're going to
do something where we actually store the
edges the raw edges that were created so
when we create the adjacency matrix we
actually lose a little bit of
information and so when we create this
edge matrix will be able to preserve
that matrix that information and and
likewise will be doing the tallies of
the edges and that as well so that's
what this does not to the set up you'll
need to modify that and this program
here actually basically in after the
setup is done it adds these accumulator
things by designating certain columns to
become what they call combiners so in
this adjacency degree table I've said I
want to create two new columns and out
degree and in degree column and the
operation that I want to be applied when
their collisions on those values is some
it will then some the values
and likewise with the edge i only have
since since i only have 1 i'm going to
have degree and some there alright so
that's how we do that so if we now go to
our database page here so you can see
class db3 it started we can actually
view the info and this is what a nice
fresh never-before-used accumulo instant
looks like as very little data it has
one table a metadata table and a trace
table this is what end and you know
there's no no errors or anything like
that so very clean instance and you can
actually and and so so that's when one
looks like we're going to use one that
we've already started though which is DB
one and we look at the tables here
there's already some tables Michelle ran
a practice run on this chance of rain of
Jack practice run I'm going to now
create those tables by five set up test
all right they're created all those
tables now see did it actually work here
so if i refresh that and you can see
it's now created these six tables which
are empty on we do have abilities to set
the right and read permissions of these
tables so right now everyone has the
ability to read and write and delete
everyone else's tables in this class
database in a project that's not so
difficult thing to manage you all know
that but you could imagine in situation
where every slick we had a big ingest
this is a corpus of data we don't want
anybody we can actually make the
permissions we can make it read-only so
that no one no one can lead or we can
make it so it's still read and write but
it can't be deleted or cloth those
permissions exist a feature we will add
to this database manager will also be a
checkpoint feature so for instance if
you did a big ingest have a bunch of
data that you're very happy with you can
check point it you know you will have to
stop the database then you can create a
check point of that stop database name
checkpoint and then you can restart from
that if for some reason your database
gets corrupted as I like to say accumulo
like all other databases is stable for
production but it can be unstable for
development new database users the
database will train you in terms of the
things that you should not do to it and
so over time you will not do to things
that destroy data or cause your database
to be very unhappy and then you'll have
a nice production database because you
will only do things that make it happy
but in that phase where you're learning
or you're experimenting with things as
with all databases any database it's
easy to do commands that will put the
database in a fairly unhappy state even
to the point of corrupting or losing the
data so um so so but for the most part
once it's up and running in production
we have a database that's been running
for almost two years continuously using
a very old version of this software so
it just continues to hum away it's got
billions of entries in it
we're not really but it's on a single
it's running out a single Mac you know
and so it's a so it definitely we've
seen situations where it's like all
other day it has the same stability of
just about any other database so now
we've created these tables and let's
insert some data into them okay so I do
the evo 6 so I'm now going to insert the
adjacency matrix there and now it's
basically ereading in each file and
ingesting that that data that's not a
lot of data it doesn't take very long
and now you can see here that data it's
been interested and you see there so we
just inserted about 62,000 in each of
those two tables and 25,000 which for a
cumulus a trivial amount you know we
just inserted 150,000 entries into a
database which is pretty impressive you
know to be able to do that in you know
essentially the blink of an eye and
that's really the real power of accumulo
is this you know a lot of other
databases 150 thousand entries you're
talking about a few minutes and here
it's just you won't even think about
doing that twice right so we can take a
look at that program so here we go so we
had eight files here and basically
loaded the data and basically one thing
we have to remember is that our
adjacency matrix has numeric values in
its Ajinca in the associative array and
accumulo can only hold strings so we
have to call the num to string function
which will convert those numbers into
strings to be to be stored so the first
thing we do is we can we we do we read
in we load our adjacency matrix
a we convert it the numeric values to
strings and we just do a put so we can
just insert the associative array
directly into the adjacency matrix and
it knows it pulls apart the triples and
it knows how to you know take care of
the fact that it recognizes this as a
transpose table pair and it does that in
just for you and likewise same thing
here now on these other things we pulled
it out we summed it convert it to
strings just do the out degree and the
same thing to do the indegree and so
this is actually where the adjacency
matrix comes in very handy because when
we're doing accumulating if we didn't
first summit and then do it we would be
if we put those raw triples into two to
insert we're essentially redoing the
complete insert and so this saves you
know usually an order of magnitude a
number of inserts by basically doing the
sum in our d for EM program first and
then just inserting those some values
just a nice way to to save the database
a little bit of trouble in in doing that
and so we certainly recommend this type
of approach for doing that right there
so the next 17 now we're going to do a
query we're going to get some data out
of that a table and so what we did here
is we said I want to pick a hundred
random vertices okay so in this case I
randomly generate a hundred random
vertices over the range 1 to a thousand
okay and I then convert those to a
string because these are no valleys and
we'll look up strings and then the first
thing I'm going to do is I want to look
up the degrees essentially of those
vertices so I have my son table here
called T adjacency degree I'm going past
those strings in and then I'm going to
get just the degrees so that's just a
big long skinny vector looking things up
from that is it takes much less time
than looking up whole
oohs and it's or columns and it stores
all those values from you so that's a
great place to start and then I want to
say you know what I only care about
degrees that have been at a particular
range this is a very common thing to do
there'll be vertices that are so common
you're like I don't care about those I
don't I have their tally and I add these
are sometimes called super nodes and and
and doing anything with those is a waste
of my time and forces me to end up
traversing enormous swaths of the
database so I'll set a upper threshold
here and a lower threshold so basically
I take a degree i'm just going to look
at the out degree i say i want things
that are greater than the min and less
than the max and i want to get just
those rows so that's this query a fairly
complicated thing analytic here done in
just sort of one line and now a new set
of vertices which are just the rose that
satisfy this requirement and then I'm
going to look those up again so I'm just
going to look up the ones that satisfy
those now I'm going to get the the whole
row of those things so before I was just
in looking up there counts now I'm going
to get the whole row and I know that
there's none that have more than this
certain value or or have too few and
then I'm going to plot it and so if we
look figure there we see so these are we
ended up finding one two three four rows
that had between the TV show all right
one two three four five six seven so
that's between five and ten these should
all be between 5 and 10 and then this
shows what their actual column column
was and so that's a very quick example
of that kind of analytic very and again
ver real bread and butter and this is
basically standard from a signal
processing seeing perspective the max is
our clutter threshold we don't want that
it's too bright and then you know we'll
have a noise threshold like we don't
care anything that's below a certain
value and this sort of narrows in on the
signal same kind of processing and
signal processing we're doing it here on
graphs and a cumulus supports that very
very nicely for us alrighty
so let's move on to the next example and
actually if we look here we go back to
the overview so you see here that was
that in jest i did this is the ingest so
very quick it's getting about 5,000
inserts a second but that was over a
very short period of time you can't even
doesn't even have time to get reach its
full rise time there and then you can
see the scan rate and it was very small
was a very tiny amount you know type of
thing as we do larger data sets you'll
really see that and this is a great tool
here you know it really kind of shows
you what's really going on um always
before you use that it is always check
this page if you can't get to the page
of the database you're not going to be
able to get to the database there is no
point in doing anything to with the
forum if this page is not responding
okay likewise if you look at this and
you see this thing is just hammering you
no way and you're getting you to seeing
hundreds of thousands or millions of
inserts a second it means it guess what
someone is probably using your database
and you might want to either pick a
different database or find out who that
is and say hey when you're going to be
done or something like that likewise on
the scan side you know likewise when you
do inserts you want to see well you'll
get some examples here of the kinds of
rates you should be seeing you want to
make sure you're seeing those rates if
you're not seeing those rights if you're
basically just you know using the
resource but only inserting at a low
rate then you're actually doing yourself
and everybody else is a service you're
you're using the database but you're
using it in efficiently and it's much
better to have your inserts go fast
because then you're out of the way you
know your work gets done quicker and
then you're out of everybody else's way
quicker too so so this is a very i
highly recommend people people look at
this to see what's going on all right so
i think the last one was seven so we're
move on to eight here so now we're going
to do another type of query we're going
to do a little bit more sophisticated
query that query used the degree tables
to sort of prune our query so we don't
have to get you think about it like
there was probably an edge in there that
had like a hundred entries you know and
we
just were able to avoid that never had
to touch that edge but if we had had
touched it you know that could have been
a much bigger query you might like 100
doesn't sound bad well it's easy to get
databases where you'll have some some
rows with a million entries your columns
with a million men trees or a billion
entries you really don't want to have to
query those rows or columns because they
will just you know send back so much
data but you can still have situations
where you're doing queries that are
going to take they're going to send back
a lot of data more data that you can
really handle ah you know in your in
your memory segment so we have a thing
called an iterator so we've created an
iterator allows you to set up a query
and have it work through it now this
table is so small that you only want to
see the iteration happening but but it
but i'll show you the setup so we'll do
that all right so there's very quick so
essentially we're doing a similar thing
we're creating a random set of vertices
here about 100 getting creating you know
but over the range of 1 to 1,000 and
we're creating an iterator here called
ta jason c iterator so the we do we it's
this function here iterator we pass in
the table then we have flag which is
element which is how many entries do we
want this iterator it's the chunk size
how many entries do we want this
iterator to return every single time we
call it and here we've set max element
to be a pretty small number to be a
thousand okay so we're saying is every
single time we do this query we want you
to return a thousand at a time now for
those of you who are a MATLAB at fish
yacht aficionados this should be you
should be in awe because a MATLAB is
supposed to be a stateless language and
there's nothing more stateful than an
iterator and so we have tricked matlab
with a combination of matlab on the
surface and some hidden java under the
covers to make it look have the feel of
matlab yet hold-hold state so so now
we're going to do is we're going to this
just creates the iterator we then
initialize the query by actually passing
in a query so we now say okay the query
we want is over this
set of rows here and so we're going to
run the query the first time and do and
since that thing returns string values
and we want numbers we have to do a
string to numb and that's our first
associative array that's the results of
the first query we then initialize our
tally here and then we just do a while
on this result okay so we're going to
say oh if there's something there then
we want to some that and add it to our
tally to our in degree tally and then we
call it again so we do the next round of
the iteration by just calling the object
with empty with no argument and it will
just saw it'll just it'll just run it
until the query is empty we put in an
argument it would reinitialize the
iterator to that new query and so you
don't have to create a new iterator
every single time you want to put in a
different query you can reuse the object
but not that it really matters but this
is how you get it to do again so it's a
pretty elegant syntax for basically
doing an iterator and it allows you to
deal with things very nicely and as we
see here then we did the calculation
here which is all right I wanted to then
return the value with the with the
largest maximum degree so basically i
compute the max I get the adjacency
matrix of the of the degree and i
compute its maximum and then I set that
equal to in degree and it tells me that
the first vertex had a degree of 14 in
this query which makes sense in the
kronecker matrix that first that 11 is
always the largest and densest densest
value so that's just how we use
iterators let us continue on here all
right now i'm going to use iterators in
a more complicated way to do a joint so
a joint is where i want to basically
maybe there's a row in the table and i
only want the rows that have one type of
you know have both of a certain type of
value in them so for instance like if i
had a table of network
records I might like look please only
return records that have this source IP
and are talking to this domain name okay
so we have to figure out how we do joins
in this type of in this in this
technology so I'm going to do that let
me run that all right so I'm trying so a
little bit more complicated obviously
we're building up sort of fairly
complicated analytics here so I create
my my iterator limit here i'm going to
pick two columns to join column one
column 2 and this just does a simple
join over those columns so basically
what I'm doing is I'm getting I'm saying
please return all the columns that
contain this is an or basically either
column 1 or 2 i'm going to then convert
those values which would have been
string values of numerics to just zeros
or one then i'm going to some that so
basically i got the two columns i
converted all the values to 1 i'm going
to sum them together okay and and then
I'm going to ask the question where were
those equal to two those show me the
records so that's what I'm doing here
I'm saying those equal to do so that
shows me all the records where that
value is equal to two and I can then get
the row of those things and then pass
that back in to the original matrix okay
and now i know now i will get back those
rows with those things and so we can see
that i think that's the first figure
that we did here you go to figure 1 and
those show basically to what did we do
right
this shows us the complete rows of all
the records that had the value 1 so this
is here one and I think it was a hundred
which is somewhere right like probably
in there so there's you know basically
every single one of these records had
you know one and 100 in it and then it
shows us all the rest of the values that
are also in that netted record we just
wanted those columns and those values
then we were done when we just some them
in equals do we were done but this
allowed us to them go back into the
record and now into them into the full
set and just get those records so this
is a way to do a join if you can hold
the complete results of both of those
things like you know give me the whole
column you know one in a whole column
two that's one way to do a joint
perfectly reasonable way to do a join
I'm going to now do this again but with
a column range so i'm going to say you
know I want all columns I want to do
join of all columns that begin with 111
and all columns that begin with 222 so
so that would return morons i'm going to
create two iterators now to do that so I
have initialized my iterator iterator
one and iterator to all right and so now
i'm going to start the first query
iterator here by giving it its column
range that initializes it and I get an A
one and then I check to see if a one is
not empty if it isn't empty I'm going to
then summit and then call it again until
its proceeds and since this is such a
small thing it only went through that
once okay and then now I'm going to do
the same thing again with the other
iterator and sum them to get together
again okay
and now I'm going to join those two
those two those two columns and that's a
way of doing the drawing with
essentially two nested iterators and
doing doing the join that way so that's
something you can do if you couldn't
hold the whole column in memory and you
wanted to build it up as you went that's
a way to do it with iterators then see
here there's an example of the results
from that right and just so you know I'm
when you do an SQL query in SQL database
this is what it's doing under the covers
it's trying to do whatever information
it can it will some lot of Dave's or
hold a lot of internal statistical
information it's trying to figure out
can I hold the results in memory or can
I not do I have to go through and chunks
or do I not do I have information about
oh you know this query like you know do
I have a some table you know sitting
around that will tell me oh which which
you know which column should i query
first because it will return fewer
results and then I can go from there
type of thing so so this is sort of all
going under the covers here you get the
the power to do that directly on the
database and it's pretty easy to do so
you have but you do have to understand
these concepts all right so now we'll
move on okay now we've done so that was
all with the adjacency matrix and as I
said before when we form the adjacency
matrix we threw away a little
information right because if we had
multiple fit a collision of any kind
right we lost the distinctness of that
that that record or that edge and a lot
of times like no we want to keep keep
these edges because you know yeah we'll
have other information about those edges
and we want to keep things so so so we
want to we want to store that so we're
going to now reinsert the data in the
table and use essentially instead of an
adjacency matrix an incidence matrix an
incidence matrix every single row is an
edge and every single column is a virgin
and so an edge can then connect multiple
vertices it also allows us to store
essentially what we call hyper edges so
if you have an edge that connects
multiple vertices at the same time we
can do that so let's do that this this
is inserting about twice as much data so
it naturally takes a little bit longer
there and you see the edge insertion
rates that we're getting there you know
thirty thirty thousand edges per second
so let's go and see what it did to our
our data here so if we look at our
tables we can see now that our there's
our edge data set and you see we've
inserted about 270,000 distinct entries
in this Davis where there's the edge
table and there's this transpose and
there's the degree account and as you
saw before you know we had 53,000 you
know so that just shows you the
additional information let me let's look
at that program here so again we're
looping over all our files here we're
reading them in it should say this case
we are reading in the raw text files
again we're not reading in the
associative array because we just want
to insert those edges and then the only
thing we've done is that basically to
create our edge we had to create this
data didn't come with a record label so
we don't have any so we're constructing
a unique record label for each edge here
just so that we have it for the row key
and then we're prepending the word out
and you know out into the row string and
in into the column string so that we
know you know when we create our record
they'll be you know out is shows the
direction it came from and in shows the
direction it left and so that's a way of
sort of creating the edge and unlike
wise we do the count a degree and such
to preserve that information so we can
summing the the note total number of
counts there
alright so let's do some queries on that
alrighty so I'm going to get going to
ask for a hundred random vertices here
so i get my random vertices and then i'm
going to do my query of the strings but
i have to prepend the this out / than
the value in it so i know i'm looking
for for for you know vertices from which
the edge is departing and i'm going to
get those edges so i get those edge so i
created the query i get the edges i'm
going to do my threshold in again i want
to certain min and Max and then I'm
going to do the threshold so this just
gave me the degree counts and I
threshold it so that you know between
this range and then now I then do the
same thing back with the with the I I
say give me everything greater than
degree min and less than degree max I
get a new set of rows so that will just
return the edges that are a part of
vertices with these degree range and
then I'm going to get all those all
those edges all the records that contain
those those vertices through this nested
query here result is this so basically
this shows me all the edges that are our
parts of vertices this random set of
vertices that have a degree range
between five and ten this is a fairly
sophisticated analytic in terms of you
we got a lot of we're doing about seven
or eight queries here doing a lot of
mathematics and you see how how dense it
is and hopefully from what we've learned
prior in Prior has some some intuition
for you
right we'll continue on all right so now
I'm going to do a query with the
iterator again same type of drill I set
the maximum of elements the iterator I
get my random set of things I create an
iterator again setting the number of
elements i initialize the iterator to be
over these vertices I then check to see
if the if it returned anything if it did
I'm going to then actually pass that the
the rows of that back into the into it
to get the edges containing those
vertices and then do a sum to compute
the indegree and so on and so forth and
then I get here the maximum in degree of
that set of vertices was 25 so that's
just an example of that and that was 12
and I think 13 is our last one
alright again a more complicated example
showing basically a join over this space
creating essentially a couple of sets of
edges a couple of column ranges
iterators and so on and so forth and I
won't belabor this point but this just
shows how you can combine between using
the degree table and iterators you
should have all the tools at your
disposal that any type of query planning
system would have inside it that it
would use to make sure that you're not
over taxing the results that you're
returning you know to and that's a lot
of times if you do a query on any
database you get the big spinning watch
or whatever it's because the query you
asked was was simply too too too long it
also gives a lot of nice places to if
you're mehdi making a query system to to
interrupt it so if you do the query
against the counts you can quickly tell
the user look you just did a query and
this is going to turn 10 million results
do you want to proceed you know and so
you course could all that we're likewise
you can set a maximum number of
iterations it's like it says okay I want
to get them back in in units of a
hundred thousand entries but I only want
to go up to a million and then I'm going
to pause and you know get some kind of
additional guidance from the user to
continue so those are the same tools and
tricks that are in any query planner you
know very elegantly exposed to you here
for managing managing these types of
queries are with that I want to do some
stuff where we do a little bit of bigger
data sets of kind of walk through the
examples I want to kind of show you what
this is like running on a bigger bigger
data set so let's crawl as close all
that right close that's
did I want to do this one so now i'm
logged into I just ssh into class DB 0 2
dot plow LOLOL MIT to you which happens
it tells you which note it's actually
math 2 which is node f dash 1511 in our
cluster and this is a fairly powerful
compute no these are our next generation
compute nodes for Ella grid so those
you've been using ello grid for all
these past years may have noticed that
the getting a little long in the tooth
these are the first set of the new nodes
and we'll have about 500 of them total
in various systems and so here I am
doing something a little bit a larger so
let me see here examples so I'm on my
elevate account here and I'm going to go
to 32 all right I do open dots alright
so that's the directory and so the first
thing I did is in my DB set up here
you'll notice that I have done class DB
0 okay and also we don't need to do one
but I will do to hear I've made this
bigger so I've made this now 2 to the
18th vertices instead of what I had
before so let's go out anymore so I do
pdb 02 it's going to now generate these
things and so it's generating a lot more
data and you see is doing at about a
couple hundred thousand reduce disease
per second just shows you a difference
between the capability of my laptop and
one of these one of these servers here
okay and this will also I'm log onto the
system it
32 cores I can do things in parallel and
so for instance if I did eval p run for
those of you who have had the parallel
matlab training I can save you for and
if I just since i'm logged into this
node and I just do curly brackets says
just launched locally on that note don't
launch onto the grid and now it's
launching that in parallel on this node
data one did that data to that now it's
done and the others finish their work to
probably right about now so that's just
an example of being able to do things in
parallel you know we've created here I
mean you look at it and we did you know
what 8 x 300 dog we did two and a half
million edges in that in that
essentially five seconds type of thing
so we receive you know stink magic
multiply this by four you're doing like
a million edges a second just in that
one one type of calculation their move
on TPB be 0 3 and 0 i should say i did
modify that program slightly let's see
here right so i look at
the the line labeled in big capital
letters parallel I uncommented it that's
what allows each one of the processors
when they launched and then work on
different files otherwise they all would
have worked on the st. but you know the
same files so byoung commenting that
parallel this now becomes a parallel
program that I can run with eval p run
command of course you have to have
parallel matlab installed which of
course you all do since you're on Ehlo
grid but for anyone seeing this on the
internet they would need to to have that
software installed to which is also
available on the web and and installable
there so that's all we needed to do is
uncomment that one line to make that
program parallel and did the right thing
for us as well and we're going to go on
to the next example and we did the same
thing there we did we just uncommon in
parallel and it's now going to you know
create these associative arrays in
parallel so if i do p DV three osos
justice now actually constructing these
associative arrays you see it takes
about four seconds to do each one of
those it's doing them at about a hundred
and you know twenty thirty thousand
entries per second so this thing will
take about 25 seconds to do the whole
whole thing
and again we ran that in parallel it
automatically tries to kill the last job
you ran if you're in the same directory
so that you're not stomping on top of
yourself and now you see us doing that
again I know it's done so again and the
other ones a finished as well actually
check that you really want to control Z
if I do more I start out you can see
those from the output files of each one
of them I'm not lying they didn't take
ridiculous on you know you always
encourage people to check those out
files in that Matt MPI directory that's
where it sends all the standard out from
all the other nodes it's probably the
number one feedback we get from a user
who says my job didn't run we're like
what does it say in your doubt files and
usually like oh there's an error on node
3 because this calculation is wrong on
that particular note or something like
that so just reminding reminding folks
of that moving on so that was we just do
we did three so we did tdp-43 test this
is doing a little bit bigger calculation
and so you can see here I told you it
does begin to get bigger here so it
started out you know the first iteration
was about point six seconds then it goes
on to point point eight seconds if we
did that cat approach it would do it it
would do it faster when I run it and
basically I loop over each files here
I'm just doing this to this little AG
thing just to sink sink the processors
just for fun so I don't go wait for them
to start and then it's going to go and
they're going to do their sums and then
when they're all done
they're going to call this globe so each
one will have a local summit it needs to
be pulled together so we have this
function called gag which basically
takes associate of race and we'll just
some them all together and very nice
tool for doing that and of course we had
to uncomment that in order for that to
work and so let's go give that a try and
so if we do eval so it's launching them
and it's reading and then I was going to
have to wait a second okay so then it
took about two seconds to pull them all
together and do the sum across those
processors so that's a parallel
computation you know a classic example
of what people do with ello grid and can
do with the forums they have a bunch of
files each processor process them
independently and at the end they pull
something all together using this either
this this gag gag command alright moving
on so now I'm on database to hear i'm
going to go to that let's look at our
tables very little activity you see we
have no tables there so have to create
them so i'm going to do p DD be set up
Phi that's going to create those tables
on that database right and we can now
look see voila created all my table so
now I'm ready to go now we're going to
do the insert again pdb 6 i'm going to
sort the adjacency matrix
and this obviously takes a little bit
longer I just each one of these well
there's a parameter associated with the
table which is you think normally it
should just send all its data to the
database at once but it turns out one
thing we found is that actually it
prefers the database prefers to receive
the data in a smaller increment
typically around half a megabyte chunk
so every single time it's calling this
extending half a megabyte waiting to get
the all-clear again and then setting the
next one we've actually found that it
can makes a fairly significant is so you
can see here we're getting about 60,000
inserts per second this is from 11
processor and this takes a little while
see if we can go and look at it while
it's going on go here we should begin to
see some so there you go see that's
that's what a real inserts beginning to
look like it just changes its axis for
you dynamically here but we're getting
about 660,000 inserts a second there you
just go along here it'll start leveling
off a little bit
and I'll show you what's going on tables
there
and just I mean you know not too many of
you will probably database aficionados
but 60,000 inserts a second on a single
node database is pretty darn amazing I
mean you would mostly have had to use a
parallel database and that's actually
one of the great powers of accumulative
problem even though it's a parallel
database there's a lot of problems you
can now do with a single node database
that you would have had to have a
parallel system to do before and that's
really because you know parallel
computing is a real pain I mean I should
know and and so one of the best if you
can make if you can make your parallel
problem fast enough to now work on a
single one that's really a tremendously
convenient capability all right so we
inserted there what eight million
entries right so pretty impressive but
that did take a while you know and so
maybe I want to do that in parallel so
if I just do evil you run let's try
let's try for now to expect actually
this to begin to top this thing out and
so the individual in search rates on
each node probably go down a little bit
and you'll see it'll get a little bit
noisy here because now we have four
separate processes all doing inserts you
see there was one it took a little bit
of almost a second and get this noise
you need to happen here but we're
getting 50,000 edges per second on one
node which means we should be getting
you know like close to four times that
so let's go check with what's it seeing
here so if we update that and there you
see we're sort of now climbing the hill
well over a hundred thousands that was
our first insert there and now we're
entering the second one here don't want
to check my email do I
see here's how are we doing there oh
it's done so I don't even know if we got
we we may not even gotten the full rise
time of that yeah so it basically
finished before we could even hit the
really hit the you know it has a little
filter here has a certain resolution you
really need to do an insert for about 10
minutes before you can get really a
sense of that but you know there you see
you know we probably got over 200,000
inserts a second using four processes on
one note and so again and we could
probably keep on going up this ramp you
know for this data set I'd expect we be
able to get maybe five hundred thousand
inserts a second if I kept editing
processors and stuff like that again so
and if you look at our data right you
know what do we got here oh yeah like 15
million entries now in our database
again one of the nice things is for
typical databases a lot of times like
you have to reinvest the whole database
that's fine in our cyber program we have
a month of data and we can readjust it
in a couple hours and that's a very
powerful tool to be able to like oh you
know what I didn't like the ingestion
that's fine I'll just rewrite the
ingestion and redo it and this is gives
you a very powerful tool for exploring
your data here so that's kind of what i
want to do with that one of our students
here very generously gave me some
Twitter data and so I wanted to show you
a little bit with that Twitter data
because it's probably maybe a hair more
meaningful than this abstract chronic or
graph data and by definition Twitter
data is about the most public data that
one couldn't imagine think no one who
posts to twitter is expecting any sense
of privacy there so i think we can we
can use that okay so let's see here that
alright that's Twitter alright and so
basically just a few examples here the
first thing we did is construct the
associative array so let's start up here
and i think it was like a million
twitter that right a million a million
entries and how many Twitter how many
tweets do you think that was well we
should be able to find out right you
should be able to find out so here so
it's reading these in chunked and
writing them out to associative arrays
that's going to be mine let's go to the
faster system
so this is running on the database
system and I broke it up into chunks of
10 I couldn't quite on my laptop fit the
whole thing in one associated race so I
broke it up in two chunks of 10
yeah see we're still cruising all right
so that just reads it all in and fact we
can take a look at that file so i just
took that exact same example and just
put his data in so just to take a look
with that involved pretty much all the
same I there was it was one big file but
I couldn't process it I mean I could
read it in each one of the row he did a
great job of creating into triples and I
can easily hold those triples but I
couldn't quite construct the associative
array and so I basically just go through
and find all the separators and then
basically take them out of the the
vector in memory and so that's what i'm
doing here is i'm looping over here so
basically i get i read in all the data i
find all the separators and then I go
through and it's a little bit of a messy
calculation to basically do them in
these particular blocks and then I can
construct the associative array and save
those out no problem and let's see here
so what else do you can do it a little
degree calculation from that data so
it's not reading each one of those and
computing the degrees there's the same
thing on this system pretty fast
see then to scrape some tables I so I
create a special class tables for that
modify that go over here was on this one
no I did it on its one tables oh all
right so all I was doing there was on
the other one it's plotting the degree
distribution so this shows us you know
so for each tweet oops there for each
tweet let's go to figure 1 for each tool
all right hey done it's very Twitter
like no no one has ever done in Twitter
so wow what did I do I went to Taunton
done now alright so we go to figure 1
all right you see for each tweet this
shows us how much information was in
each tweet and you see that on average
just because he basically parsed out
each word uniquely so this just shows
there's about a thousand pieces of
information associated with each each
tweet seems a little high so we should
probably double check that and then what
did I do so we load it all them up we
sum the degrees and then oh I said I
show me all the locations greater than
with with that with crowns greater than
100 and all the and then all the words
with at signs greater than 100 and all
the hashtag greater than 50 so that's
what these other guys are so so this was
the essentially for each tweet how many
you have
we go to figure 2 this shows the degree
distribution of all their words and
other things in there so there's some
guy here is really really high in fact
we can find him out and so but as of
course most things you know occur only
once slated once like there's a lot of
unique keys in like the there's the
message ID which of course is probably
something it all appears once if we go
to figure 3 so this just shows like the
locations and this was tweets from the
day before the hurricane or the week the
wednesday before the hurricane hurricane
sandy and so this shows us you know to
put in the limited to the kind of a new
york area or something like that or 40
or miles around new york city though
basically it shows us all the locations
here and you see so this is a classic
example the kind of things you want to
do because the first thing that we see
is that we have some problems with our
data which is New York City in New York
City space got to go in and correct all
those right so that's a classic example
this is really what D for em it's the
number one thing that people do with the
forum is it's the first time that you
really can like do sums and tallies over
the entire data set and these things
just pop out they stick out like a sore
thumb you know like 20 got to correct
that you can either correct in the
database or corrected afterwards in the
query but that just immediately improves
the quality of everything else you have
and then there's this clutter one like
location none right well clearly you'd
want to just kind of get rid of that or
do something with that and then just
plain old normal spelled New York so
most people can spell correctly and so
we're for good but location iphone I
mean what's that about you know jersey
city well we don't care about that you
know so South Jersey well what's South
Jersey people don't know that there are
40 miles from New York I guess sir in
their profile so a lot of people in
South Jersey who say they're from New
York so I guess what's your name jersey
shore
snooki right Snooki says she's actually
from New York City not not jerseys not
South Jersey so so so there's a great
example of that and then let's see here
figure 4 so this just shows all the the
at sign so you see basically damn its
true is like the most this is like a
retweeted thing or something or I don't
know know know what it was the at sign
mean again it means to a new to you so
most people tweet too damn it's true in
New York there you go funny fact a
relatable quotes and then Donald Trump
the real Donald Trump and then just word
at sign so those are the other example
you know anything here's a hilarious
idiot bad gal V and Marilyn Monroe ID I
mean so there you go a lot a lot a lot
of fun stuff there on Twitter but this
is sort of he's going to establish his
background and it's go back and look at
during the hurricane so this is all
basically the normal situation and then
you know very court clearly and then the
the hashtags right so we can look at the
hashtags so what do we got here favorite
movie quotes and favorite movie quotes
miss de Velde right up there the Knicks
and then what I love the most and all
this type teamfollowback I don't know
team auto know what's this word what's
tfb nobody maybe we don't want to know
so can always look that up in urban
dictionary and then it's a bad one all
right okay good well then we'll leave it
at that won't add that to the video um
so continuing on here let's see that
well you get the idea and so all these
examples they work in parallel to get a
lot of speed up lots of interesting
stuff like that but that's very
eat plastic the kind of thing you do you
get data you parse it you maybe stick it
in MATLAB files to do your initial sweep
through it but then if it's really
really big and you want to do certain
more detailed things and you insert in
the database can do queries their
leverage using your count so that you
don't accidentally you know you can
imagine we put all the tweets in the
world need location New York City you
looked at you had to like give me all
this set of locations and one of them
was New York City you'd be like oh my
god I've just you know have done a query
that's going to give me five percent of
all the data back what's going to just
flush your system but if you can just do
the count and be like all New York
City's got a million entries don't touch
that one you know or put an iterator on
that one right you know so that so that
I only handle it in manageable chunks so
so I want to thank you so hopefully this
was worth it we have one more class
which deals with a little bit to
wrapping up some of the theory kind of
on this stuff and some stuff on
performance metrics and then in two
weeks for those of you signed up we have
the accumulative Oaks coming in showing
you how to run your own database you
know all day on just you know you know
we're setting up a database for you for
you guys on ll grid but you're
definitely going to run in with your
customers accumulo instances it's good
to know some basics about that because a
lot of times you're not going to have
all the kind of nice nice stuff that we
provided and it's good to know how to
set up your own accumulo and interact
with that in the field so with that that
brings the lecture at the end and happy
to stay for any questions if anybody has
them